[Music]
if you've traveled the las vegas strip
you probably noticed the progress
at resorts world slated to open in the
summer of next year
and right now they're starting to hire
sally jaramillo joining us now live from
the property
and sally they've got a job fair coming
up this weekend right
yes denise while construction is still
happening here
it's time to start finding the right
employees now resorts will need to fill
more than 6 000 positions
resorts world has been a partner with
share village for some time now
and we're just very excited to be able
to partner with them in this event
lori calderon is the executive director
of talent acquisition
and community engagement at resorts
world she tells me job opportunities are
available for ages 16 and up
at a job fair saturday at share village
2
on north 21st street and fremont next
year not only are we going to open this
incredible resort we're going to bring
all of the individuals in that are going
to bring it to life
the hiring process may be different due
to covet 19
circumstances and the fact that they
will be a technology savvy resort
so you can count on things done
virtually on-demand virtual career fairs
they can expect things such as virtual
interviews
all kinds of things that will allow them
to do things more on their own time
some advice for saturday come dress to
impress
bring extra copies of your resume and
wear a mask
the pandemic has really changed a lot of
things i think in our whole communities
especially in business
and we have the ability in the luxury of
looking at things from a resort that
isn't open yet
so that we can build and develop things
to be safe
and secure the job fair is from nine
til noon other employers at the job fair
include amazon dignity health and
staffing agencies
we posted all of that information on our
website 8newsnow.com reporting live from
resorts world sally jaramillo 8 news now